i just need to text back
brian danielson
right here
well i just did
let's go how are you okay
let's go hey uh okay okay so the thing
does that make sense what's that the
thing i was talking about
he's on
hi i'm tony kahn i'm the owner chairman
president ceo founder
booker head of creative
and a few other things for all elite
wrestling aew
i was a tv kid i watched the a-team and
hulk hogan played himself on the a-team
so that was pretty cool but i didn't
know that was a real person i just
thought that was a guy on tv at first
and then i watched g.i joe and the host
of g.i joe was sergeant slaughter but i
didn't know he was a a wrestler and then
i saw ads for wrestling and hulk hogan
and sergeant slaughter were part of the
wwf so i thought that was pretty
interesting and then i watched more of
it and that was when i was eight years
old and uh i've never looked back in the
last 30 years of being a huge fan
i'd always dreamed of starting a
wrestling company but there was actually
a very viable business case and reasons
to do so in 2018
the meteorites for wrestling television
had gone very high and i think they're
going to continue to rise because
wrestling is so strong in the
marketplace right now on tv when i
started working on this in 2018
the contracts we knew were going to
fetch hundreds of millions of dollars in
guarantees so
it begged the question would there be
space for a competitive wrestling
product that could also demand big
rights fees on television i thought so
yes instead of having a big touring
model and people wrestling hundreds of
times a year to me the bread and butter
was going to be the tv product so i
happened to be friends with kevin reilly
who at the time was president of tnt and
tbs and he introduced me to the team
there and really uh they put us through
the ringer big time before they signed
up for this and right out of the gate
with no tv contractors i started to lock
up honestly millions and millions of
dollars in guarantees to sign up
wrestlers for multi-year deals and
there was a unique opportunity at the
time in the marketplace because there
were a lot of great wrestlers who were
not under contract we had to really go
out and prove ourselves and we did we
did really good numbers immediately and
once we proved we could establish
ourselves and then continue maintain
those really strong numbers we received
a 175 million dollar contract from tnt
and through the pandemic that was really
what kept us going in a lot of ways
without the live event revenue coming in
because we we were the number one
wrestling touring company in the world
in 2019 on a per show basis
we had the highest average number of
paid fans per show of anyone and then in
2020 you go to having no paid fans and i
tried to be the first to bring fans back
to the live event experience uh but
still you know at 25 capacity and
everyone physically distanced and
in the outdoor space and everyone masked
it was it was great but also
business-wise i mean the ratings picked
up because i think the shows are more
fun with the fans there and also that
live event revenue is great and we've
been doing uh fantastic with our live
tours through the last several months
since we came back in july august and
september
[Music]
today in arthur ashe stadium the aw
grand slam it's a very typical show day
in some ways in other ways it's been
absolutely crazy nobody had ever done a
wrestling show in arthur ash stadium
which is this amazing venue and like the
most amazing wrestling city in so many
ways this great market with great fans
it's our attendance record uh including
the suites we'll have over 20 000 people
here which is a first for aw i'm always
going through the show i'm going through
ideas you know there's all the matches
talking to the people in the matches
making sure the show goes smoothly a lot
of stuff happens on the day of people
come up with new ideas and if there's a
good idea that we can incorporate on the
day of then we're going to talk and i'll
make a late call so i'm making some
audibles as we say in football at the
line of scrimmage as i go here and it'll
be really fun i want to put a crash pad
here it doesn't need to be the whole
show but when for rampage i want
something here because i think we i
think we should toss fuego off and have
you down and then make you like watch it
or whatever that'd be great
on screen i think we have a lot of
conflict but backstage it's a great
environment i mean there's always
creative conflict but for the most part
you know the vast majority of the time
we have a great working relationship
with each other and i try to start that
from the top i think there's literally
over 100 people out here i have really
good relationships with and that starts
with personal relationships and for me i
have a lot of things to do but i'm not
bandwidth to make time if you're on
dynamite or rampage it's a big deal and
i'll be spending time talking about what
we're going to
[Applause]
do being around tony khan is infectious
and he's a wrestling fan i'm a wrestling
fan that's why i'm here today tony khan
has a real passion for pro wrestling he
started aew for the right reasons and
changed wrestling history as a result
tony is a prime example you don't have
to be a wrestler to know our business he
was a lifelong fan he studied it he
studied the business of it and the
creative of it and every idea he's ever
presented to me it's been great
for one thing it's incredible how much
stuff he actually does and still is able
to keep track of everything how he
doesn't have eight assistants that are
all on the different projects that he's
doing i really don't know he does
everything himself it's really
motivating working with him to see him
succeeding and thriving in so many areas
all at the same time it just makes you
want to work harder
[Music]
when we started aw dynamite just over
two years ago in october 2019 it was a
tough fight for
a couple years they had never been
number one on cable until april 14 2021
and since april 14th now we've had
several number one finishes and a really
hot run of them recently with the launch
of aw rampage
we had to get bigger and better and make
this the best time in the history of aw
which i think it really has been in
terms of every major business metric
television ratings pay-per-view
viewership live events
merchandising we're at all-time highs
and all these metrics so it's definitely
the most exciting time in the history of
our business really hasn't been anything
like what we're doing in terms of
competing head-to-head with wwe
week to week in the cable ratings in two
decades and this is all now a
head-to-head two-team competition in
many ways so it is the most focused i
think the fans have been on a
head-to-head competition in a long time
because there haven't been two companies
that were able to generate hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue
since the late 90s
[Applause]
you